durante las últimas horas en la
televisión estatal rusa ha emitido
imágenes mostrando a más de mil
supuestos marines ucranianos que se
rindieron a primera hora del miércoles
estas imágenes no han sido verificadas
pero se dice que han sido tomadas en la
zona industrial de la asediada ciudad de
mariupol donde los últimos soldados
ucranianos han ofrecido una dura
resistencia
en la ciudad de mariupol cerca de la
fábrica de hierro y acero de willis como
resultado de las ofensivas exitosas de
las fuerzas armadas rusas y las unidades
de la milicia de la república las de 10
mil 26 soldados su craneanos de la
brigada 37 infantería de marina de
pusieron voluntariamente las armas y se
rindieron por
el ministerio de defensa ucraniano no
saben nada de una rendición y es que las
fuerzas rusas continúan sus ataques
contra azotes tal y la zona portuaria no
obstante un funcionario del gabinete
presidencial ucraniano reconoció el
martes que las fuerzas ucranianas
estaban rodeadas y bloqueadas en
mariupol el miércoles el alcalde dijo
que las fuerzas de la ciudad seguía
resistiendo
hay que decirlo muy claramente su
situación es muy difícil porque le
superan en número pero están resistiendo
mariupol sigue siendo una ciudad
ucraniana la ubicación de mario pool es
estratégica si la ciudad cae daría a
rusia un puente terrestre para las
tropas y los suministros entre las zonas
que controlan al este y al oeste de la
ciudad las autoridades ucranianas
afirman que hasta el momento entre 10 y
22 mil personas han muerto en la
localidad